we have just heard from the White House
after President Trump sounded off again
about the raids involving his personal
attorney and the Russia probe the
president certainly has been clear that
he has a very deep concern about the
direction that the special counsel and
other investigations have taken this
investigation started off as rush of
collusion of which there was none that
has been very clear that nothing has
come up over the last year and the
president spoken at length on this topic
while the media continues to focus on
this despite the fact that there's been
no evidence after a year we're going to
continue to stay focused on the issues
well this morning the president fired
off another furious tweet calling the
Russia investigation fake and corrupt
headed up by all the Democrat loyalists
he said Muller is most conflicted of all
except Rosenstein who signed the FISA
and Comey letter no collusion so they go
crazy
as the president fumes some lawmakers
are trying to get a bipartisan bill pass
to head off any attempt by the president
of fire the Special Counsel Sarah
Sanders said yesterday it is within mr.
Trump's jurisdiction to do so I think
that the president has been clear that
he thinks that this has gone too far I
believe he has the power to fire special
counsel robert muller dizzily that's
within his power certainly believes he
has the power to do so all right
Kimberly let's start with the raid that
we didn't get a chance to talk about the
other day it looks like they've been
investigating mr. Trump and not
president Trump for almost two years
they found no evidence of any crime nor
any Russia collusion evidence and
they're now going off into his personal
attorney - I guess look for payments to
stormy Daniels and now it looks like
it's an FEC violation where do you think
that's headed well can you imagine
though and when at the inception where
this investigation was supposed to go
and now where it has traveled far beyond
what the original initial scope is now
if you come across something while
you're doing an investigation that's one
thing right but nevertheless there's
been such kind of a wide swath and net
cast here trying to get anything that
they can it seems in terms of trying to
bring something against the president
through Michael
Koen etc obviously they're not going to
overlook if there is any wrongdoing but
nevertheless let me tell you something
cuz I had a case where I prosecuted for
homicide two attorneys very complicated
to do because all of the things in their
house when we had the search warrant
issued have attorney-client privilege on
them they're privileged they're
confidential you have to get appointed a
special master to go through all of
those documents to make sure that you
are not taking anything improperly the
clean team right and here they refer to
it as a clean team exactly so they had
to go through his hotel room at the
Loews okay his apartment and the office
so they got a judge to sign off on this
they have to have and they better have
some really compelling probable cause
and evidence to be able to support this
kind of service because every American
doesn't matter if you are a Democrat a
Republican a libertarian leaning Green
Party whatever you want to do this can
happen to you as well the the safeguards
of the law exists for a reason so they
will not be abused to protect the rights
of American citizens guess what
including the President of the United
States and his personal legal counsel so
from here let's see what they're able to
come up with this is very aggressive and
heavy-handed there isn't any legal
scholar that I've listened to that
doesn't you know agree that this is an
aggressive move and really I'm
unprecedented yeah Alan Dershowitz the
other day said that the constitutional
rights of Michael Cohen were violated
people are saying this is a little
unfair when you look at how Hillary
Clinton was treated
Michael Cohen's been cooperating with
the special counsel he's produced almost
a million documents and then they raided
his house Hillary Clinton shredded a lot
of documents and was exonerated so
people think there's a little bit of an
unfairness factor here Dana
perhaps in the DOJ is Inspector General
Michael Horowitz is investigating that
piece the Michael Cohen himself said
yesterday on television that the FBI was
very courteous and respectful he had no
problem with things that it's not
pleasant he doesn't like it but there
was all that then you find out about the
process and the high bar that you have
to clear with a judge and others
including political appointees like rod
Rosenstein
have to sign off on this type of thing
and if I don't know if it really is all
about stormy Daniels I have no idea but
that whole payment situation is such an
own goal and they whatever happened with
The Wall Street Journal finding out the
information in January issuing that
story then she comes forward and all of
this stuff is coming out together I know
that it was all of this stuff happened
before the election right but if they
brought it into the presidency right and
so I don't know what all they're going
to find I I think that obviously the
country has a lot going on with many
different things like we're gonna talk
about in the next segment a possible
military action against a really bad
actor but I also think that the system
looks to me is working the way it is
supposed to so I guess you know on a
technicality you're right it is but I
mean if you make a payment Greg to
someone for a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in the midst of a
campaign and you don't report it to the
FEC I guess that's some sort of campaign
finance violation you could serve up to
five years in prison and face twenty
five thousand dollars in fines that
would probably be how they're trying to
squeeze Cohen maybe to flip Cohen on
Donald Trump yeah perhaps I think and it
didn't something similar with Obama and
a campaign violation had to pay a fine
for but you can look that up if you want
look that you brought up Dershowitz
briefly he's no fan of Trump II voted
for Hillary he doesn't even think I
don't even think he thinks Trump is a
good president but I haven't seen one
person disagree with Dershowitz without
without in first impugning his motives
and that's always a sign for me that
they can't argue with Dershowitz if you
have to go straight to insulting him
like what I think was Toobin said to him
was a couple of weeks ago it said like
what happened to you that's when you
know you're winning but here's the
narrative so you got it this outsider
right who is elected to disrupt the
system and boy does he disrupt the
system this is a truly radical
presidency and we're watching it all
over the place from North Korea to
what's happened with China and
everything this system is disrupted the
media is convulsing the Democratic Party
is wandering in a haze so the opposition
is going through all their tools to
unseat this guy and they they find this
one weapon that they weren't originally
looking forward to removing and it's
it's something that happened but
for the election nothing I've said here
is false that's exactly what's happening
we had a radical elected to the
government who's disrupted the system
and now there's an opposition trying to
unseat him with something that happened
before the election they tried to do
with the Access Hollywood right now the
public is going to sense this if this
this is why I have to wonder if the
anti-trump errs are thinking this all
the way through because the public will
sense that you this is a political coup
using past personal behavior and this is
going to turn Donald Trump into a folk
hero a combination of Johnny Appleseed
and Paul Bunyan because he's going to
appear to be the victim because you're
taking him out not over policy you're
taking him out over personal behavior
that occurred prior to the election if
you hate Trump get a load of pence
that's all I got to say he's gonna make
Ronald Reagan look like Abbie Hoffman
okay Juan do you think that there is any
overreach in terms of rating the
president's personal attorneys house and
office and hotel room no but if there is
that would be a tremendous act of
indiscretion as we just heard Kimberly
described I thought quite accurately but
I said what ask all of you to consider
for a moment that in fact the people who
approve this Jessi are all Republicans
try talking about the FBI director
Christopher Rae we're talking about rod
Rosen Stein right the Trump appointee as
the Deputy Attorney General we're
talking about Jeffrey Berman who is the
US attorney in New York they all had to
approve of this step of the FBI going in
to Cohen's hotel Berman or his office I
think you might have recused no I I
don't know but I don't know that for a
fact but what I do know is this that
Trump in essence brought this on himself
so we can talk about oh people who hate
Trump and all that but it was President
Trump who said last week that he knew
nothing about the payment of money by
Michael Cohen technically his lawyer
some people say as a fixer to this woman
Stephanie Clifford stormy Daniel then it
turns out that once he says that there
is no lawyer-client privilege because if
that's the case he's not representing
the president United States and the
president the United States is now in a
position where he's either lying
about not knowing about this money or
there's some secret benefactor who has
given money for this and therefore has
leverage to potentially blackmail the
President of the United States which is
why I think it has set off alarms not
only in the law-enforcement community
but nationwide okay let's talk about
Rosenstein because you said that he's a
Republican and a lot of Republicans
approve this
he does have some conflicts we know the
president mentioned those during his
tweet storm as they like to say I mean
he's overseeing an investigation of
obstruction of justice over the firing
of James Comey and he was the one that
authored the letter recommending the
firing of James Comey and then he was
the one who appointed Muller he also
signed off on all the surveillance
warrants and now it's his own department
that's Stonewall in Congress to find out
the documentation about the warrants so
and now he's overseeing this entire
investigation it's it just seems like
when you look at the way Hillary was
treated and then you look at the
conflicts that Rosenstein has president
feels like he's being unfairly treated
here Kimberly and rules apply to other
people that don't apply to him and vice
versa well he's been you know quite
vocal and transparent about his upset
and the fact that he's thinks that this
was unfair that this investigation was
supposed to be about one thing but now
it seems to be very personal and a way
to try to unseat the American President
duly elected and that's what a lot of
people are gonna feel very strongly
about across the country you've seen
some of the reaction about it and Greg
is a touched on this point but now he's
faced with another decision which is
he's upset about it right but it is an
ongoing investigation what does he do
about it what is he legally able to do
what is within his rights and what is
politically smart for him to do because
there's some decisions here that would
be a problem for him if he were to fire
Muller okay then there's also the option
which has been widely discussed over the
last 24 hours
as to whether or not he should remove
Rosenstein due to some you know
conflicts of interests that have
presented across the board here in terms
of some of the investigation there's tie
in psyco me to Muller what's going on
here should there be on another Special
Counsel assigned to investigate that
whether or not there was any kind of
I'm underhand the things going on or
some collusion there in terms of a
concerted effort we don't know but
that's something that a special counsel
could also take a look at and you've
seen some people talking across
television and writing about that today
as well I think the president's gonna
sit back for a bit here and see what
happens and transpires because I think
that the problem would be too if he were
to act you know hastily it's sort of
like what right now okay we're circling
scene we're gonna do about Syria
he's certainly seen what he's gonna do
about this situation here I think if he
starts firing Muller right you got
Republicans today beginning with Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell saying
don't do that
well I get the Senate want him to fire
Muller no voting the President to fire
Mullen daring the president to do that
especially I mean it was going to just
to reiterate what Dana just said I think
you could make the case that there's
some Democrats who see him stepping in a
bucket if he was to do that but you have
Republicans Jesse lining up and saying
don't do that that would be the end of
your present we will not back you there
are lots of Democrats who feel like
people like Paul Ryan who made the big
announcement today but totally spineless
in the face of a guy who's
anti-immigration who's blown up the
budget who doesn't believe in trade but
they had back Trump but on this one
they're saying don't touch my Lindsey
Graham when people are scared not to do
I am just trying to step back and look
at the long term here because all the
people that are involved in this do not
have a plan they are running barreling
towards us impeachment Nirvana and they
have nothing after that and the point is
this is Donald Trump is not a normal
politician that you can nail on affairs
or on sex you're taking out the most
disruptive political outsider that I've
seen in my history whether you like him
or not that's what he is he is not a
traditional politician so if you take
him out in a manner in which feels like
cheap or CD or new or unjust because
it's it's about sex that happened before
you're gonna have half the country going
like okay you took the biggest threats
that we have ever seen in our political
lifetimes out over a role in the
I don't see how is actually in trouble
in any way about stormy Daniels to your
point I think Michael Cohen could
possibly because of that decision but I
don't see it actually bearing any
problems for president joke except for
possibly PR but there you can't impeach
somebody for that I will dig it for them
I know that they don't like no you know
what I probably conflated two things
what I've been reading is that they are
hoping for such a wave of Democrats that
there would they will do the impeachment
your point it's interesting because
unless the President had already prior
like gone in and made statements and was
interviewed by Muller and there were
perhaps inconsistent statements false
statements anything like that that by
which then they could you know impeach
him with materials that were found
obtained and there'll be legal battles
over whether any of that can be you know
introduced or used as well was it
lawfully obtained so that I mean this is
I'm not gonna sad to say it's not going
to end quickly no I think it's safe to
say the president will not be sitting
down with the special counsels office
after that anymore